اذا مشاهدينا نتابع هذه
المسيره التي ضربت بالقرب من
القصر الرئاسي
وتم استهدافها اذا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
الان على شاشه العربيه وهو استهداف
الطائره المسيره التي كانت تحيط بالقصر
الرئاسي في كاز وطبعا هذا الامر متوقع منذ
الامس وروسيا تقول بانه الرد سيكون قريب
جدا
وسيكون بالمثل وكان هناك تصعيد كبير منذ
الامس بين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا بعد هذا
الاستهداف بالامس للكريم للنمل اذا هذه
المسيره كانت بمحيط القصر الرئاسي في كييف
وتم استهدافها ونتابعها بهذه الصور بشكل
واضح
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور طبعا الاستهداف
هذه المسيره التي كانت بالقرب من رئيس من
القصر الرئاسي وهذا الرد متوقع بعد هذا
التصعيد الذي حصل بالامس واعتبره البعض
بانه تصعيد
وتطورات خطيره وتداعيات ستكون خطيره كانت
روسيا اتهمت كياف طبعا
باستهداف الكريم ومن وراءها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وصل الامر لان يقول
دماتي ميدفي رئيس الامن القومي بانه يجب
قتل الرئيس زيلينسكي واعضاء حكومته ودائما
كاذب منذ الامس وهي تنفي اي علاقه لها
بهذا الاستهداف للكرملين حتى اليوم الرئيس
رينسكي في لهاي قال بانه نحن لا نريد قتل
الرئيس ولا اي احد من القاده نحن سنترك
العداله تاخذ مجراها كان هناك ايضا مواقف
دوليه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه دائما
كانت تشكك باتهامات
روسيا لاوكرانيا او حتى للولايات المتحده
حتى بالامس نائب
متحدثه باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه كان معنا
ضيف ووصف هذه الاتهامات بالسخيفه ايضا
اليوم كانت هناك مواقف لايطاليا ولفرنسا
وكلها باطار بانهم حتى الان لا يعرفون اي
تفاصيل عما حدث ولا يريدون اتخاذ اي موقف
تجاه هذا الامر من دون ان يكون حصلوا على
تحقيقات وعلى معلومات وادله معينه ولكن
الكل اجمع بانه يجب ان يكون
المسار السياسي مع روسيا دائما مفتوحا
وانهم ضد اي استهداف
لمثل هذه المقر واستهداف اي قاده في
العالم
ايضا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا
كانت لها مواقف اليوم بانها لا تعطي
كياف اي اسلحه لان تستهدف افراد وانما هي
تقدم اسلحه الى كاف للدفاع عن نفسها وكذلك
طبعا اعضاء حلف الناتو هذه الصور الان لما
حصل بالامس يعني هناك يعني على هذه الشاشه
مقسومه قسمين
المسيره التي تم تفجيرها فوق الكريملين
وايضا على الجانب الاخر من الشاشه المسيره
التي ايضا تم اسقاطها الى جانب هذا القصر
الرئاسي فيك على كل حال زميلنا حذيفه عادل
اصبح جاهزا معنا حذيفه ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل حول هذه المسيره في اي منطقه
بالذات هل يمكن ان تعطينا صوره عن جغرافيه
هذه المنطقه التي تم استهداف هذه المسيره
فوقها
نعم مساء الخير في الحقيقه هذه المسيره تم
اسقاطها في منطقه الصالون
مسكي هو حي كبير جدا ولكنه في تقريبا في
وسط العاصمه اكيد هذا الحي يبعد حوالي 20
دقيقه تقريبا بالسياره من مكتب الرئيسكي
مركز المدينه بشكل عام من مركز صنع القرار
بشكل عام سقطت اشياء هذه الطائره المسيره
على منزل سكني مكون من اربعه طوابق احدث
حريق جزئي في هذا المبنى وعمده المدينه
قال انه لا يوجد اضرار كبيره حتى الان لا
يوجد اي بلاغ او طلب للنجده الطبيه كما
قال وهذا يدل على انه لم يكن هنالك مصابين
في هذه
في هذا المبنى او في المنطقه التي سقطت
فيها اشياء او اجزاء من هذه المسيرة هذه
المسيره الحديث يدور على يمكن ان تكون
مسيره تستهدف مكان ما ويمكن ان تكون هذه
المسيره ايضا
تراقب وتجمع معلومات على الرغم من انه
يعني حتى الان لم يتم التاكيد اذا كانت
تحمل متفجرات او لا ولكن
هنالك اكثر من روايه يمكن ان تكون تجمع
معلومات بحيث انه دائما لا يتم الاستهداف
فقط بمسيره واحده وانما بعدد من المسيرات
حتى اخر استهداف الذي تم ب 24 مسيره كان
الكييف نصيب من هذه المسيرات وبالاضافه
الى صاروخين ايضا اليوم طبعا تعلمين ان
هنالك كان استهداف بسته صواريخ في منطقه
وكذلك في روزا الاستهداف وتيره القتال
ترتفع شيئا فشيئا منذ اسبوع يعني وحتى
الان ويتوقع ان ترتفع اكثر واكثر طبعا
الان الاجواء بدات تسمح بمزيد من الحركه
للقوات وكان الروسيه او الاوكرانيه تغيير
الطقس قد يسمح بمزيد من التصعيد في جبهات
القتال وهذا ما تنتظره كيف لتنفيذ الهجوم
المضاد بالنسبه
لاستهداف هذه المسيره مثل هذه الاوقات
ايضا
تدور سفارات الانذار في كاف تنزل الناس
الى الملاجئ ام لا
نعم يعني نلاحظ ان المواطنين لا يلتزمون
بالنزول الى الملاجئ سواء كان في مناطق
سكنهم او حتى الماره في الشوارع
السيارات تسير طبعا والمفترض ان تتوقف
السيارات ان لا تتحرك ان يبحث الانسان عن
اقرب ملجا ويلجا اليه ولكن المواطنين لا
يلتزمون بذلك تحدثنا الى عدد كبير منهم
يعني في الفتره الماضيه وهذه العاده اصبحت
منذ عده اشهر يعني عند الاوكرانيين عندما
تحدثنا اليهم يعني يقولون انهم تعودوا على
صافرات الانذار اصبح الامر ليس مخيفا كما
كان في السابق لكن الجدير بالذكر ان
المراكز التجاريه تتوقف تماما يتم اقلاع
الناس منها كذلك المؤسسات الحكوميه وحتى
الشركات الخاصه يتوقف هذا الزامي هذا
قانون يعني يخرج الموظفون الموظفين ويخرج
الناس من المراكز التجاريه الى الطريق
تتوقف المواصلات العامه سواء كانت ترانفاي
او الترمايه المترو الانفاق او حتى البساط
تتوقف فتره الغاره الجويه في المكان الذي
كانت فيه وتنتظر حتى انتهاء او حتى
الاعلان عن انتهاء الغاره الجويه طبعا
الغار الجويه تم الغاءها قبل حوالي نصف
ساعه من الان الان الوضع طبيعي جدا الان
الناس تباشر حياتها بشكل طبيعي كنت اقف
قبل قليل بالقرب من احد المنازل السكنيه
يعني المتعدد الطوابق وفيه اكثر من مجمع
سكني لاحظت انه لم ينزل احد الى الملجا
وفقط وجدت سيده ومعها طفلين وكذلك اسره
مكونه من شخصين من جمله عدد كبير جدا من
المساكن والشقق يعني اتوقع ان هذا المبنى
فيه اكثر من الف شخص ولكن لم ينزل احد
لاحظت ان جميع النوافذ او اغلبها مضاءه
وهذا يعني ان هنالك اشخاص في هذه الشقاق
ولكنهم لم ينزلوا هذا الامر يعني اصبح
بشكل كبير في اكيد وحتى في بقيه المدن حتى
في تلك المدن القريبه من جبهات القتال في
نيكلايف على سبيل المثال في خرسون على
سبيل المثال فكره التي اصبحت اقرب المدن
الى الجبهه ايضا المواطنين لا ينزلون الى
الملاجئ
ابقى معي حذيفه ساذهب الى عبد الجواد عبد
الجواد اهلا بك معنا كما نتابع الان بانه
ايضا هناك مسيره كانت بمحيط القصر الرئاسي
ايضا تم اسقاطها هل هناك اي تعليق من
الجانب الروسي على هذه المسيره
مساء الخير ميسون لك ولحذيفه حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد اي تصريح او اي اعلان رسمي
من الداخل الروسي لا لكريمين ولا الخارجيه
تحدثت عن هذه المسيره طبعا ميسون لم لم
تكن لم تكن وزاره الدفاع خلال عمليتها
العسكريه بالتصريح او الاعلان عن المسيرات
التي تطلق نحو الداخله الاوكراني لكن طبعا
بما يخص المسيرات منذ
ساعتين من الان طبعا اتجهت حكومه شبه
جزيره القرم وتحدثت عن اسقاط مسيره عبر
انظمه الدفاع الجوي ايضا مدينه المتاخمه
للاراضي الاوكرانيه وهي من الجهه الغربيه
الشماليه لروسيا ايضا شهدت سقوط مسيرات
عبر اصطيادها بانظمه الدفاع الجوي ايضا
مسيرات اخرى طالت بعض المناطق على الشريط
الحدودي ومعظمها تم الاعلان عنه داخل
الاراضي الروسيه طبعا ميسون لابد من لفت
الانتباه كنا نتحدث واياك منذ ساعتين حول
التصري الرسميه من قبل روسيا ان كانت من
الخارجيه او الكريمينال حول الرد بما يخص
المسيرات التي وصلت الى الكرملين طبعا في
اخر التصريحات موسكو تتحدثوا على لسان
الخارجيه بانها متاكده بشكل كامل لانه
سيتم العثور على منفذي
والمتورطين بهذا العمل في الداخل الروسي
وستقوم بمحاسبتهم بشكل كبير حتى هذه
اللحظه الاعلان الرسمي ميسون بما يخص نقطه
انطلاق هذه المسيرات لم يظهر بعد وما زال
التحقيق جاري بما يخص هذا الموضوع هذا
قضيه جنائيه اطلقتها موسكو ويعمل فريق
كبير بما يخص هذا الموضوع لدراسه خط سير
هذه المسيرات ومن اين انطلقت وما هو
المسار الذي عبرته وما هي الجهه او الوجهه
التي كان من المقرر ان يصل اليها على
العموم ميسون الوضع في موسكو حتى هذه
اللحظه هو مستقر نوعا ماروما القلق الذي
يسمع بشكل كبير ان كان على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او على شاشات التلفزيون بما يخص
وصول هذه المسيرات الى العمق الروسي لكن
طبعا مركز المدينه هو نوعا ما مغلق كما
عادته في هذه الايام من السنه ليس المركز
بشكل كلي مغلق وانما الشوارع رئيسيه بجانب
والساحه الحمراء هي مغلقه لوصول العربات
العسكريه بحيث يقوم طبعا القائمون على
العرض العسكري في 9 مايو بالتدريب
والاعداد لهذا العرض الكبير والذي من
المتوقع حسب القراءه في البلاد ان تقوم
موسكو بالاعلان او اشهار سلاح جديد لديها
ربما قد يحدث هذا في التاسع من مايو ميسون
عبد الجواد ساذهب الى ناديه بلبيسي مديره
مكتب العربيه من واشنطن ناديه اخر المواقف
والتصريحات من قبل الولايات المتحده تجاه
ما حصل في موسكو بالامس ولا ادري اذا كان
هناك اي موقف تجاه هذه المسيره التي تم
اسقاطها بمحيط القصر الرئاسي في كاف الان
اهلا بك ميسون وبالزملاء في الواقع قبل
قليل جون كاربي كان هنا في الاجاز الصحفي
اليومي اولا التعليق كان على اتهامات
كليمن لواشنطن بانها او لكياف بان
المسيره انطلقت من قبل الجهات الاوكرانيه
اولا قال كيربي بانه يريد ان يؤكد بان
الولايات المتحده ليس لها اي علاقه لا من
قريب ولا من بعيد بهذه المسيره ايضا قال
بان التحقيق لا يزال مستمرا يعني لم يرد
ان يؤكد بشكل قاطع مئه بالمئه بان
الاوكرانيين غير متورطين في هذه المسيره
لكن على الاقل هو يرى منذ امس واليوم
بالتحديد بانها هي حجز تستخدمها
موسكو بالتحديد لشن هجوم على اوكرانيا وهي
من وجهه نظر واشنطن هو تصعيد خطوه تصعيديه
لهذه الحرب لانه الرئيس بوتين من ناحيه من
وجهه نظر واشنطن مره اخرى
يرى بانه قد خسر ربما التاييد الشعبي ومن
هنا عندما يقول بان هناك محاوله اغتيال
بين قوسين كما يقول البيت الابيض ربما هذا
يساعد على تجنيد عدد كبير من الجنود مره
اخرى او لان يكون هناك دعم شعبي جديد او
زخم لهذه الحرب التي كما تعرفين كما هي كل
الحروب في مرحله معينه يكون هناك ربما
معارضه لها او ملل منها او محاوله
لانهائها لكن على الاقل واشنطن تقول بانه
المعلومات الاوليه ربما بانك هي غير
متورطه فيها لكنها لم تؤكدها مئه بالمئه
بالنسبه للاعتداء الجديد حتى الان لم يصدر
اي رد واضح من البيت الابيض لكن هي
بالنهايه تضع كل هذه الاعتداءات بالاطار
العريض وهو ان روسيا التي قامت بشان هذه
الحرب على اوكرانيا بان روسيا التي انتهكت
السياده الاوكرانيه وبان بهذا الحرب يمكن
ان تنتهي خلال ساعه اذا رئيس بوتين بالفعل
ان ينهي هذه الحرب ساذهب الان الى
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه سيد
مكتينكو اهلا بك معنا ما هو تعليقكم
الاولي على هذه المسيره التي تم استهدافها
بمحيط القصر الرئاسي
مساء الخير تحيات من كيف
كيف الان يعني تقريبا
يعني ليله قضت الليله ولكن قبل الساعه ان
في ناس كثيرين اللي شافوا عده مسيرات كانت
فوق كيف ولكن انا لست متاكد بان فوق
الاداره الرئاسيه لان انا شفته بعيني وانا
ساكن يعني الى حد ما بعيد عن الاداره بس
كانت يعني مسيرات تدور يعني فوقنا
وقوات
مضاد يعني قوات الدفاع الجوي كانوا
بيضربوا عليها يعني من قاذفات ومن رشاشات
فالحمد لله
قدروا ان اسقطوا على اخر واحد
مسيره
وانانيه هل هناك من اي اضرار هل هناك من
اي اضرار او اي خسائر بشريه او اصابات انا
الان فتحت
الانترنت بعد من
مواقع اوكرانيه هو تؤكد بان عدسه حدث هاي
تم هاي حدث قبل 40 دقيقه تقريبا والحمد
لله ما في شيء ولا ضرر ولا شيء ولا ولا
جرحه ولا قتله ولا حاجه
هل من نعم انا اكرر من جديد نحن للاسفه
الشديد
متعودين على
هاي مسيرات وهاي مسيرات للاسف الشديد هاي
حياتنا منذ 14 شهر
وندبر حالنا
ولا هلا ولا ولا حاجه يعني
هل التحقيقات لمعرفه اذا لانه هناك عده
روايات بانه من الممكن ان تكون هذه
المسيرات فيها متفجرات لاستهداف القصر
الرئاسي او محيطه او تكون اسم سيارات من
اجل التجسس هل هناك وقت طويل من اجل معرفه
طبيعه هذه المسيرات
انا برايي
الفكره الثانيه من اجل التجسس لماذا لما
تيجي هاي المسيره هناك عده مسيرات
واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه فهم يصورون يعني
الهم اهمهم يصورون
بيعرفوا مواقع
للاجهزه او مدافع للمضاده
المضاده للطائرات ومضاده للصواريخ هاي شيء
مهم في كل الحرب نحن في نعمل نفسه شيء
ولكن مش في روسيا في مناطق المحتله
الاوكرانيه اللي الان روسيا لا تزال تحتل
18 تقريبا في الميه من مناطق من مناطق
تابعه لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لسادتناكو عاده هل تعلمون من اين تنطلق
هذه المسيرات ام من الصعب معرفه ذلك
[موسيقى]
في خيره الروس يتغيرون في بعض الاحيان
كانوا كنا منتظرين دائما من الجنوب الان
تيجي مسيرات من الشمال اما من ولكن هاي مش
اكيد ولكن اكيد من منطقه او محافظه اسمها
برانسك هاي في شمال في شمال اوكرانيا
ومحافظات اخرى ولكن لا تزال
مسيرات تيجي من من جنوب من جنوب اوكرانيا
من من يعني جنوب تقريبا روسيا طب سيد هل
تغيرت
طبيعه الاجراءات المامنيه المكثفه حول
المقر الرئاسيه ايضا مركز رئاسه الحكومه
الاركان بعد هذا الاستهداف بالامس كاملا
وهذا التصعيد والتهديد من قبل روسيا
لاستهداف
واستهداف زلينس كشخصيا واعضاء حكومته
انا اكرر لكم
وللمشاهدينا الكرام بان الان السيد الرئيس
الاوكراني كيف في زياره رسميه في اوروبا
امبارح هو كان في فنلندا اليوم هو يزور
هولندا ويزور مدينه لاهاي وكمان القى كلمه
مفيده جدا ومهمه جدا
لكلمه
لا يوجد سلام بدون عداله اي كان يتحدث عن
هذه الكلمه عن هذه الاشياء في
في مقر لمحكمه جنائيه دوليه في لاهاي فهاي
والله خطوه مفيده ومهمه جدا جدا جدا وهو
التقى كمان اليوم
باقاده هولندا اما
الخطه يعني القادمه انا ما اقدرش اقول لكم
حاجه
سيد مكتينكو ايضا هذا التصعيد البعض
يعتبروا بانه خطير جدا وتداعياته خطيره
جدا هل اوكرانيا مستعده
لحرب مفتوحه هل قادره ان تبقى صامده
والله نحن نحود الحرب الحرب الدفاعيه منذ
14 منذ سنه 2014
[موسيقى]
من زمان من زمان بس غايه الحرب كان غير
مولد او غير معروفه لكثير من يعني
[موسيقى]
بلدان والشعوب في العالم بس ابتداء منذ 24
فبراير هذه السنه جاريه الناس عرفوا شو
ماذا يجري هنا في اوكرانيا اوكرانيا اكبر
دوله مساحه في اوروبا على فكره الان
18% من مساحه اوكرانيا مختله بالروس فهو
يقولون حتى اخذوا قوانين الجديده
وكاتبوا في الدستور
الروسي روسيا بان هذه المحافظات تابعه
للروس عباده ونحن في قرن 21
اي معقول ام لا
المفاوضات والمسار السياسي برايكم غير
قابل للحديث عنه بهذه الاوقات
جيدا نقول حرب تنتهي بالسلام
بمفاوضات السلام ولكن ماذا بدنا نحن
يعني سلام عادل ونحن
نريد
سياده اراضينا
واستقلال اوكرانيا واوكرانيا في حدود 91
طب ما هي حدود هذه التنازلات سيد ماكتينكو
للوصول الى سلام يعني من المعروف عندما
يكون هناك صراع وحرب او عمليات عسكريه يجب
على الطرفين ان يقدما بعض التنازلات ما هو
حدود هذا التنازل من قبل اوكرانيا حتى حتى
تنهى هذه الحرب حتى تنتهي هذه الازمه
انا يعني كنت اشاهد كثير من الازمات
خصيصا في شرق الاوسط الازمه في لبنان
الازمه الحرب العراقيه ايرانيه والى اخره
الى اخره يعني محادثات السلام
تحتاج الى الهدوم
خلينا لا نستعجل وخلينا الناس المسؤولين
سوف يبدا محادثات محادثات بس على اسس
السليمه وعادله زي ما قالها
في محكمه هاي
فمدت
متطلباتنا عادله شكرا لك شكرا لك من كافه
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
ابقوا معنا مشاهدينا لنتابع هذا تقرير عن
معركه المسيرات ودورها في الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه ومن ثم نعود لمراسلينا
ايضا لنتابع بعض التطورات
نجمه الصمود الاوكراني كما وصفت دعمت عمود
المساعدات الغربيه العسكري وصنعت الفارقه
في الحرب لا سيما ان استخدامها جاء من
الطرفين لتحديد مواقع العدو وتوجيه نيران
المدفعيه نحوها
على اعتاب كييف كانت المسيرات الاوكرانيه
اول من اقفل الباب بوجه القوات الروسيه
لتسحب ذيولها خلال ساعات وتتفرق شرقا
وجنوبا فيما الخاصره اي شبه جزيره القرم
التي زرعت الشوكه الروسيه فيها منذ تسع
سنوات تتعرض كل حين لهجمات بالمسيرات
هدفها الاولي قطع امداد المعدات والغذاء
عن موسكو واستهداف اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
جيش الدرون الاوكراني الذي قلل من اضرار
التفوق الروسي حجما وقدره شمل بدايه
مسيرات تجاريه رخيصه الثمن الصينيه الصنع
دي جي اي مافيكا حضرت صادراتها بكين لاحقا
على اعتبار انها للاستخدام المدني فقط لكن
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه شكلت العين
الاساسيه على اوكار الخصومه تحمل كاميرات
استطلاعيه ويمكن تسليحها بقنابل موجهه
بالليزر واستخدمت بالهجوم الذي اغرق سفينه
موسكفا الروسيه في ابريل 2022 لكن هذه
المسيرات يعيبها حجمها الكبير وبطؤ حركتها
وسهوله اسقاطها مقارنه بكمكاز الانتحاريه
فالعصافير القاتله او الذخيره المتسكعه
تتميز بقدرتها على التحليق في منطقه الهدف
المحدد مسبقا وتضرب عند التعرف الى العدو
تطلق من مسافات بعيده ويصعب اكتشافها لصغر
حجمها اهميه هذا السلاح ادركته موسكو
سريعا فاندفعت الى ايران لشراء مسيرات
انتحاريه عمياء بدقه ضعيفه استخدمتها لاول
مره في خركيف ثم كياف واوداسا وميكولياف
غير ان هذه المسيرات لم ترقى لتوقعات
الروس واخفقت كثيرا وفق واشنطن
اعود الى مراسلي العربيه من كييف حذيفه
عادل ومن موسكو عبد الجواد ساذهب اليك
حذيفه ايضا لتطلعنا على الوضع هل هو هادئ
هل هناك تخوف هل من مسيرات اخرى ما زالت
تحلق مثلا فوق سماء كيف
يعني الوضع هادئ جدا حاله الانذار والتاهب
الجوي بعد ان الغيت لم تعد السلطات وتعلن
عن اي حاله تاهل جوي طبعا تم الاعلان من
قبل عمده المدينه كلشكو ان
يعني الشظايا او الجزء من المسيره الذي
سقط في المنزل المكون من اربعه طوابق يعني
اندلع فقط حريق على الهيكل فقط ولا يوجد
اي اصابات ولا يوجد اي اضرار كبيره كذلك
هنالك في منطقه جزء صغير ايضا سقط في منزل
وايضا تسبب حريق ايضا بسيط جدا وحتى الان
لا يوجد اي ضحايا وتم تاكيد ذلك ولا يوجد
اي اضرار كبيره من جراء هذه المخيرات لابد
ان اؤكد ايضا ان هذه المسيرات اسقطت في
منطقه بعيده بعض الشيء عن مكتب الرئيسكي
او القصر الرئاسي يعني منطقه وهي تبعد
حوالي 20 دقيقه بالتشيسكي تبعد حوالي 10
دقائق تقريبا من
الرئيس فهي لم تصل الى محيط
قصر الرئاسه او مكتب الرئيسه او حتى
الوزارات ومناطق صنع القرار اسقطت قبل ذلك
قبل ان تصل ولكنها استطاعت ان تصل الى
مركز المدينه في الحقيقه هذه المنطقه كلها
في مركز مدينه كيف في سنتر مدينه كيف في
الضفه اليمنى طبعا عمليه الاستهداف
بالمسيرات
سوف تقابل في الايام القادمه
بنظام رادار اسرائيلي ليس فقط المسيرات
وانما يعني الاستهداف بالصواريخ حتى
الباليستيه وكل انواع الصواريخ بنظام
رادار اسرائيلي كما افاد السفيره
الاوكراني في اسرائيل الذي قال انه سوف
يتم تسليم هذه هذا النظام
الذي سوف يكون متواجد في العاصمه كيف
تحديدا لحمايه العاصمه من اي استهداف
يستطيع ان يقرا من على البعد اي نوع من
انواع الصواريخ يستطيع ان يحدد السرعه
يستطيع ان يحدد نوعيه الصاروخ تستطيع كذلك
ان يحدد المنطقه التي والحيه التي يمكن ان
يسقط فيها وقطر وحجم الضرر الذي يمكن ان
يسببه ان يسببه هو ذلك سيساعد المضادات
الجويه في التقاط هذه الاجسام التي تتجه
نحوك على كل حال ايضا نتابع هذه الصور
التي وصلت وهي من زياره الرئيس
الى هولندا اليوم حيث ايضا كان له كلمه في
لهااي وطالب فيها ان يصلوا الى السلام
ولكن من خلال العداله كما كان له بعض
المواقف بانهم لا يستهدفون الرئيس الروسي
ولا يستهدفون اي قاده في روسيا وانما
يتركون للعداله ان تاخذ مجرها ساذهب مجددا
الى عبد الجواد الرشد زميلنا في موسكو عبد
الجواد هل هناك من اي تعليقات او اي
تصريحات
من خلال او على هذه المسيره التي تم
اسقاطها في كاف وكانت في محيط القصر
الرئاسي
ميسون يعني على الصعيد الرسمي حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تعلن لا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ولا الكريمينال ولا الخارجيه اي معلومات
حول هذه المسيره لكن كما نلاحظ من مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه من تيليجرام وعلى
الصفحات الرسميه للكثير من وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه يتم الان نقل مقاطع الفيديو نقلا
عن شهود عيان في كيف يعني تظهر محاولات
اسقاط هذه المسيره والمكان الذي سقطت به
وخروج طبعا السنه النار نوعا ما على يعني
على ما يبدو ان الصوره هي اقرب لحذيفه
هناك لكن طبعا بعض الاخبار تتحدث على الان
عن ان الفتره الزمنيه التي احتاجتها
القوات الاوكرانيه لاسقاط هذه المسيره
استمرت قرابه 20 دقيقه كما ذكرت يعني هي
معلومات يتم نقلها على صفحات تيليجرام
التابعه لوسائل الاعلام الروسيه نقلا عن
شهود عيان من الاراضي الاوكرانيه من كييف
لكن الصوره هناك هي لدى طبعا الزميل حذيفه
طبعا ميسون لابد من لفت الانتباه الى ان
بعض وسائل الاعلام بعد خروج هذه المسيره
تطرقت للحديث عن ان موسكو لم تقم ولا مره
طبعا منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه بالاعلان
بشكل دقيق بما يخص المسيره هي تعلن طبعا
بشكل يومي خلال تقريرها عن نتائج العمل
خلال 24 ساعه عن خسائر القوات الاوكرانيه
من معدات ومن جنود وغير ذلك من ضربات تطل
البني التحتيه لكن بما يخص الخطط واستخدام
المسيرات فهو موضوع طبعا ترى فيه موسكو
موضوع سري ولا يمكن الافصاح عنه حتى ان
القانون الروسي يحاسب من يقوم بنشر
المعلومات في حال قام بالحصول عليها ولو
بشكل رسمي حتى ولو كانت صحيحه ميسون لذلك
طبعا كما هي العاده لن ننتظر او لن نتوقع
كما ترى الدائره وكما يرى التحليل السياسي
في البلاد والعسكري لن تقوم طبعا وزاره
الدفاع
يا مهتمه ميسون دون ادنى شك وهي لا تريد
ربما ان تستبق الاحداث يعني ما قاله كاربي
قبل قليل هو بان الاداره تقوم بجمع كل
المعلومات من كل الجهات حتى تستطيع ان
تخرج بنتيجه نهائيه لتحدد الجهه التي قامت
بارسال هذه المسيره
لضرب الكرملين وبالتالي اعتقد بانه سواء
كانت الاستخبارات البنتاجون البيت الابيض
هنا وزاره الخارجيه جميع هناك تنسيق كبير
بينهم لمعرفه بالتحديد ماذا حدث لكن ايضا
قبل قليل كيربي كان يقول بان اشاره روسيا
الى ان الولايات المتحده متورطه في هذا
الحادث هو عباره عن رغبه روسيه
ربما بوضع هذا اطار لهذا الصراع وكانه
صراع بين الولايات المتحده وحلف شمال من
جهه وما بين روسيا من جهه اخرى هي منذ
اليوم الاول كما قال كيربي الاداره عفوا
روسيا تقول بان هذا الصراع هو الصراع
بالوكاله وهو صراع مباشر ما بين موسكو
وبين واشنطن وهو امر تنفيه تماما واشنطن
وتقول بانه روسيا هي الدوله المعتديه
اعتقد بان هناك متابعه على اعلى مستوى
سواء كان في مجلس الامن القومي او في
البانتاجون بالنسبه لمعرفه من هو المسؤول
عن هذا وكما قلت على الاقل يعني كما ذكرتي
في الخطاب السياسي الذي يصدر من البيت
الابيض يقول بان موسكو تبحث عن حجج حتى
تصاعد من هذا الصراع وحتى تقوم بمحاوله
اغتيال الرئيسكي يعني لا يوجد هناك ايه
اسرار على الاقل من وجهه النظر الامريكيه
بان روسيا كانت تسعى منذ اليوم الاول
لاغتيال او اعتقال الرئيسكي وبقي عصيا
عليها ومن هنا ربما هو مبرر لها بانه قامت
بارسال هذه المسيره من جهه من وجهه نظري
هي اوكرانيه والان روسيا ترد بالفعل لكن
نرى بان هناك ربما
توافق في بالنسبه للضربات يعني لا يوجد
هناك ضربه اكبر من ضربه على نفس المستوى
تقريبا ترد موسكو هذه ربما من وجهه نظر
واشنطن بان خطوه يعني محسوبه حتى لا يكون
هناك صراع جديد مفتوح على اعلى مستوى
واشنطن تريد ان تتفاداه باي طريقه شكرا لك
ناديه بلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه كنت معنا
من واشنطن طبعا نحن نتابع ومازلنا نتابع
هذا التطور ايضا وهو اسقاط مسيره بمحيط
القصر الرئاسي طبعا ليس هناك من اي تفاصيل
حول هذه المسيره ماذا كانت تحوي هل هي
مسيره تجسسيه هل هي مسيره من الممكن ان
تكون تحمل يعني قنابل وهي لتفجر فوق القصر
الرئاسي لا معلومات من حول ذلك ولكن ما
نعرفه حتى الان بانها سقطت في محيط القصر
الرئاسي وبعيده الى حد ما عنه كما ذكر
الان مستشار وزير الخارجيه
وبانها تسببت ببعض الاضرار الطفيفه ليس
هناك من اي اصابات بشريه وحتى الخسائر
الماديه ليست بكبيره حسب ما ذكر الان ايضا
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الان ينضم الي من
موسجيني المحلل السياسي سيد يا فيجيني
اهلا بك معنا هل هذه المسيره التي تم
اسقاطها
من الممكن ان تكون بدايه من الرد الروسي
تحيه لك والاساده المشاهدين الان كل
الاحتمالات وارده ولكن ما معنى يعني اطلاق
مثل هذه المسيره طالما ان الرئيس لينسكي
غير موجود في اوكرانيا وهذا الامر ربما
يدفع الى الاعتقاد بان روسيا قررت ان
تاكدت الانبار بان المسيره هي الروسيه فهي
قررت ربما ان تعطي ردا مماثلا لما قامت به
اوكرانيا باطلاقها مسيرتين على الكريم
واضح تماما ان انه كان هناك معلومات بين
غياب الرئيس بوتين في اثناء هذه
الاستهدافات ووضح ايضا ان استهداف المقر
التابعه للرئيس الاوكراني ربما اذا كان
بالفعل قد تم منذ ساعات فهو يعني اهميته
السياسيه اكثر منها عسكريه ما الرساله
التي تود روسي كانت بحال كانت روسيا وراء
هذه المسايره ما الرساله التي تود ان
ترسلها وكما قلت الان بانه رئيس في كاب
اصلا
رساله واضحه تماما روسيا لا يمكن ان تقف
مكتوفه الايدي اذا هذه الاستهدافات التي
تاتي وتصبح تحديا بالغ الخطوره بالنسبه
لروسيا الان حين لم يبقى الا ايام معدودات
حتى الاحتفال بعيد النصر وهو من اهم
الاعياده في روسيا تقليديا يقام عرض عسكري
في مثل هذا اليوم ويحضره طبعا الرئيس
الروسي وقاده الدوله الاخرون ولا يمكن
الغاء هذا العيد ولكن استهداف الكريم من
قبل المسيرتين ربما وضع علامه استفهام حول
موضوع ما اذا كان هذا العرض سوف يجري
ويقام في الزهره الحمراء اما يمكن
حتى الان يبدو بانه يبدو بانه هناك اسرار
على تنظيم هذا الاحتفال
وهناك الاستعدادات ما زالت مستمره والان
لدينا صور مباشره من موسكو الان حيث نتابع
المكان حيث سيقام فيه هذا الاحتفال طبعا
هناك اجراءات امنيه مشدده نتابع هناك
عربات عسكريه او دبابات
وتواجد امني كثيف جدا
وعاده دائما في مثل هذا الوقت تكون هذه
الاجراءات الامنيه هي ذاتها لانه هذا
الاحتفال هو من اكبر الاحتفالات والاكثر
رمزيه بالنسبه
لروسيا
فنتابع هذه الصور على كل حال ارجو ان تبقى
معي السيد افيني وايضا زملائنا حذيفه وعبد
الجواد سنتابع هذا التقرير ومن ثم نعود
كره ثلج الازمه الاوكرانيه تكبر يوما بعد
يوم حادث المسيرتين فوق قصر الكرملين صب
الزيت اكثر فوق نيران الحرب المشتعله اصلا
موسكو وبعد اتهامها بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
صعدت اللهجه اكثر الخارجيه الروسيه توعدت
برد يكون بحجم التهديد سهام الانتقاد
الروسيه هي اتجهت مباشره نحو الولايات
المتحده فقرارات القيام بمثل هذه الاعمال
تتخذ في واشنطن وليس كيا التي تنفذ يقول
الكرملين
مثل هذه القرارات وتعريف الاهداف وتعريف
الوسائل كل هذا تمليه واشنطن على
اوكرانيا نفت الاتهامات الروسيه جمله
وتفصيلا ووصفتها بالكاذبه فرسيا اختلقت
الهجوم لكونها تعلم انها خسرت الحرب
والكرملين يستغل هذه الروايه لتحفيز جنوده
على الاستمرار في الحرب ومقدمه لعمل عسكري
شامل
اما زيلينس كيف حاول القيام بهجمه مرتده
من داخل مقر محكمه الجنايه الدوليه عبر
المطالبه بمحاكمه الرئيس الروسي
تجب معاقبه بوتين على افعاله هنا في عاصمه
القانون الدولي حليف اوكرانيا الاتحاد
الاوروبي دعا الى عدم استخدامه هجوم
الكريم ذريعه لتصعيد الحرب ويكو ندع روسيا
الى عدم استخدام هذا الهجوم المزعوم ذريعه
لمواصله هذا التصعيد للحرب اكبر داعم لكي
اف سياسيا وعسكريا الولايات المتحده ابدت
تشكيكها فيما يقع البيت الابيض قال انه
ينظر بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن موسكو في
وقت اشارت الامم المتحده الى انه لا يمكن
تاكيد المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني
على الكرملين بلال البجدين العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى تصعيد الان بين روسيا من جهه
واوكرانيا من جهه اخرى
لذلك اعلنت السلطات المحليه في شبه جزيره
القرن اسقاط طائره مسيره قرب قاعده جويه
في حادثه جديده من الحوادث المماثله التي
جرت في الايام القليله الماضيه وقال حاكم
سيبا ستوبول ان الدفاعات الجويه احبطت
هجوما اخر على سيباس بالقرب من قاعده
بلبيك الجويه
مجددا ينضم الي من موسكو يفجيني سيجراف
المحلل السياسي سيد افكيني هل من الممكن
ان نعتبر بان المعركه الان اصبحت معركه
مسيرات بين روسيا واوكرانيا
نعم هذا الوصفه وصفه حرب المسيرات بدا
يستخدم في روسيا ومن قبل العسكريين منذ
اواخر السنه الماضيه سنه 2022
وليس غريبا الان ان يعني ما يحدث الان
يؤكد صحه هذا الوصف لانه بالفعل اذا
لاحظنا وشاهدنا التطورات الاخيره لا سيما
في المناطق الحدوديه لروسيا نرى ان هناك
عدد من الحوادث التي شاركت فيه القصيرات
وكانت تستهدف تاره مستودع مثلا او خزان
النفط الوقود وتاره اخرى القطار الذي خرج
عن مساره ايضا وكذلك عدد من البلدات
الواقعه على الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه هي
الاخرى اصبحت مستهدفه من قبل المسيرات
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي ما يحدث الان
عمرو المنطقي تماما ولا غروه في ان
التهديدات والتلويحات التي قال قالها
واشار اليها العديد من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين كانت بمثابه التمهيد لما حدث
الليل قبل الماضيه وهي استهداف الكريم من
قبل مسيرتين اوكرانيتين طب سيدي يا فيجيني
بعد هذا التصعيد
يعني خاصه روسيا بالامس تحدثت عن انه يجب
قتل زيلينسكي اعضاء حكومته يجب ان يكون
الرد قاسي هذا ما قاله ايضا الدوما هل
مسيرات هي كافيه هذا هو سيكون الرد القاسي
ام نحن بانتظار ان يتم وينتهي عيد النصر
ومن ثم سنشهد تطورات ميدانيه عسكريه
بطريقه انه واسعه النطاق اكثر
انا اعتقد بان ما تقوم به الان القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا ربما سوف تستمر مثل
هذه الاعمال بنفس الوزير وبنفس
السرعه وبطبيعه الحال قبل عيد النصر لا
يمكن ان ننتظر مزيد من التصعيد لكن مع ذلك
روسيا لا تنوي ان تتراجع وبطبيعه الحال
الاشتباك هذه المره ستتغير خاصه بانه تم
استهداف الكرملين مصدر القرار رمزيه
بالنسبه
للروس وبهذا التوقيت يعني قبل كم يوم من
عيد النصر
وكما قلت احد اهداف مدبرين مثل هذه الخطوه
والاستهداف كان ربما يعني محاوله الغاء
عيد النصر والغاء العرض العسكري الذي تم
الغائه بالمناسبه في عدد من المدن
والبلدات لاسيما تلك التي تقع على مقربه
مباشره من الحدود الاوكرانيه وربما اولئك
الذين دبروا وخططوا لهذا الاستهداف كانوا
ايضا يريدون ان
يؤثر على القياده الروسيه لكي تلغي هي هذا
العرض في العاصمه موسكو وهذا الامر بطبيعه
الحال لا يمكن لروسيا ان تسمح به واكد
الناطقه لسان الرئيس الروسي بان العرض
العسكري سوف يقام والاحتفالات سوف تجري
كما كان ذلك في سنه في السنوات الماضيه
ولكن وسط اجراتي امن مشدده نراها وفي
الايام السابقه ايضا في تقريبا كل الامحاء
والشوارع والسحاط الهاشيه ما في وسط موسكو
وقرب المنشات العامه شكرا لك من موسكو
المحلل السياسي ساذهب الان الى زميلنا في
كافه حذيفه عادل حذيفه هذه المسيرات هي
دائما فوق سماء مختلف
المدن في كييف مثلا في اوديسا كان هناك
استهداف كما ذكرت لنا سابقا كان هناك
استهداف الكثير من المسيرات وتم اسقاط
العديد منها هل يمكن ان ننجز معارك
المسيرات حاليا خاصه في الاسابيع الماضيه
على كيف
نعم ميسون يعني اولا اسمحي لي ان اشير الى
ما صرح به عمده المدينه قبل قليل بينما
نحن نقف هنا وهذا المباشر يستمر اقل ان في
منطقه المبنى الذي اصيب والذي هو من اربع
مكون من اربع طوابق في الطابق الاول فقط
في الارض الاصابه اتت في احد المراكز
التجاريه لم تطال المبنى من الداخل الحريق
فقط ما سماه ما سماها بالزخارف الخارجيه
الزخارف الخارجيه وكذلك حتى الهياكل
المدعمه لم يطالها الحريق وتم اطفاء
الحريق واخماده وتم تاكيد انه لا اصابات
كذلك في منطقه ما سقط ونتج حريق صغير في
منطقه لا تتجاوز 50 مترا ايضا تم اخماده
واكد ايضا انه لا يوجد اي اصابات هذا فيما
يخص المسيرتين قبل قليل او المسيره قبل
قليل بشكل عام ميسون يعني تعبير او اسم
حرب المسيرات هو اسم حقيقي وهو الاسم الام
ما يحدث الان طبعا قبل فتره تحدثت قبل عده
اشهر تحدثت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
والاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه وقالت
انها الان رصدت شح في مخزون الصواريخ
الفارسيه والصواريخ كروز
101 وكذلك 555 وقالت ان انتاج هذه
الصواريخ يحتاج فتره من الزمن وكذلك يكلف
اموال طائله لذلك اتجهت بوسكو الى حرب
المسيرات لانها ارخص ثمن بكثير من
الصواريخ التي كانت تستهدف بها كييف
وتستهد بها الاراضي الاوكرانيه بكثافه
كبيره جدا كان يطلق بشكل شبه يومي ما يقرب
الى المئه صاروخ او ما يزيد عن ذلك وبعض
وفي بعض الاحيان اقل بقليل ولكن في
المتوسط كان 60 صاروخا يتم بها استهداف
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وخاصه منشات الطاقه
ولكنها وجدت ضالتها في المسيرات التي هي
رخيصه الثمن يمكنها ان تحقق ضرر
كبير بالنسبه لي المنشات الطاقه التي كانت
تستهدف بها في الفتره الماضيه والان هي
تستخدم في المعارك طبعا حتى المسيرات
الصغيره وكنا قد تحدثنا في قبل فتره ليست
ببعيده الى المهندسين الاوكرانيين الذين
يصنعون المسيرات التجاريه ونحن هنا لا
نتحدث عن المسيرات العسكريه وانما يقومون
بتصنيع المسيرات التجاريه ويضعون عليها
المتفجرات وكاميرات المراقبه ليستخدمونها
في جبهات القتال المختلفه هذه المسيره
الصغيره جدا يمكنها ان تفجر مدرعه ويمكنها
ان تحيب قوه كامله في يعني عربه كامله
ملئه بالجنود وكذلك يتم احيانا بها
استهداف الجنود داخل الخنادق ايضا يتم
استخدامها لاسقاط القذائف وليس فقط
كمسيره انتحاريه وانما احيانا فقط تقوم
بالغاء القاء من الجو يعني القنابل وكذلك
تساعد في فتح الطرق تساعد ايضا في
العمليات الاستخباراتيه احيانا تستخدم
يعني الاستطلاع عند التقدم للتمشيط كذلك
تستخدم هذه المسيرات وهي كما قلت قبل قليل
هي رخيصه ويمكن ان تستخدم بكثافه ولا تكلف
الاتحاد الروسي الكثير من الاموال والان
ايضا هنالك حديث حول كمقاله الاستخبارات
الغربيه وكذلك الاوكرانيه انه جاري
التجهيز لتصنيع هذه المسيرات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه وايضا هنالك اتفاقات بين ايران
وبين موسكو حول عمليه التجميع والتصنيع
داخل الاراضي الروسيه لذلك وجدت موسكو
ضالتها في هذه المسيرات التي تحقق نتائج
كبيره وهي فعاله سواء كان على جبهه القتال
او حتى في استهداف المنشات وايضا هي
تستهدف بعض المناطق التي تقول موسكو طبعا
انها مناطق عسكريه داخل المدن وكذلك مخازن
للسلاح وطبعا كيف تنفي ان هذه المسيرات
تستخلق تستهدف مناطق عسكريه وانها تستهدف
المدنيين او تستهدف المباني السكنيه وتسبب
اضرار وسط المدنيين في المدن شكرا لك
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه النكاف على كل
هذه المعلومات ساذهب الى عبد الجواد الان
لنساله ايضا عبد الجواد من خلال تحركك
ورحلاتك على الحدود كيف كانت تسير المعارك
بالمسيرات
المسيرات ودرونات اصبحت تلعب دور محوري في
سير المعارك وخاصه طبعا في المعركه بين
موسكو وكيف طبعا لابد من لفت الانتباه في
نقطه بشكل سريع ميزون الى ان موسكو اتجهت
نهايه العام الماضي نحو انتاج المسيرات
ودرونات والجميع يتذكر زياره الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين الى المعامل العسكريه
وتوجيهي واعطاء الامر بالعمل على انتاج
مسيرات وادخالها ضمن سلاح الجو الروسي قبل
الخامس عشر من فبراير من هذا العام اي
يعني قبل ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا من الان ميسون
طبعا الشريط الحدودي ان كان بين الاراضي
البيلاروسيه والاوكرانيه او كان بين
الاراضي الروسيه والاوكرانيه هو يشهد
طيران كبير للمسيرات طبعا المسيرات من
الجانب البيلاروسي والاوكراني هي تلعب دور
استفزاز نوعا ما كنا نلاحظ خروج العديد من
المسيرات نحو الاراضي البيلاروسيه واسقاط
في تلك المناطق كنا نلاحظ هذا الشيء
باعتبارنا متواجدين فقط في الاراضي
البيلاروسيه ولم ندخل الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اما طبعا الشريط الحدودي
الطويل المتاخم بين بين الاراضي الروسيه
والاوكرانيه فكانت المسيرات تطير من
الجانبين كنا نلاحظ اسقاطها بشكل كبير وما
شاهدناه في مقاطع الفيديو اليوم هذا اللون
الاحمر القريب الى الوردي نوعا ما طبعا هو
يظهر عمل انظمه الدفاع الجوي في منطقه ما
واصطيادها لهذه المسيرات هو ذاته اللون
الذي شاهدناه في المسيرات الا عندما تم
اصطيادها فوق مبنى الكرملين لذلك وضع
اعتيادي هذه المسيرات اصبحت تلعب دور
محوري كبير بدءا من بيل جراد الى كورس الى
مناطق اخرى وصولا الى روستو حتى في العمق
الروسي هذه المسيرات اصبحت تصل الى مسافات
تبتعد عن موسكو برابط 70 او 90 كم تقريبا
وهناك طبعا الطوق الامني اما ما يخص
المسيرات والتحقيق جاري بها التي وصلت الى
فحتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان الرسميا
عن نقطه انطلاقها وما هو المسار التي مرت
عبره ميسون شكرا لك عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه من موسكو ساذهب الان الى
كافه مع الصحفي محمد البابا محمد اهلا بكم
معنا ماذا لدينا من جديد ماذا لدينا من
مواقف تجاه هذه المسيره التي
اسقطت في محيط القصر الرئاسي
وللتوضيح ميسون مسيرتين حلقتا فوق العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف بالبدايه عبرت اول مسيره
في فقرات الانذار عند الثامنه مساء في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وعند الثامنه وعشر
دقائق تم اسقاط المسيره الاولى التي عبرت
فوق منطقه وهو يعني الحي الاقرب للاداره
الرئاسيه ومجلس النواب وحتى مجلس الوزراء
ولكن لم تحلق هذه المسيره مباشره فوق تلك
المراكز بل يعني كانت من الجهه الشرقيه
لتلك المنطقه حلقت الى ان استهدفتها
الدفاعات الجويه وكما راينا يعني من مكان
التصوير يعني المصور الذي صور هاتين
كان يقف في ساحه الميدان وظهر يعني اوتيل
اوكرانيين واحد المسارح المشهورين في وسط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف عبرت المسيره من
جهه وليس فوق الحي الحكومي لانه هناك لقط
كبير يتداول ان القصير عبرت فوق الحي
الحكومي وفوق المكتب الرئاسي بينما كما
ذكر ايضا واكد يعني زميلنا حذيفه ان
المسيره عبرت من منطقه كوتشينسكي وتم
اسقاطها وايضا كانت هناك مسيره اخرى كانت
تجول في منطقه سلومسكي وهلاسيسك
هذه المسيره اسقطت وهي بعيده جدا عن
المراكز الحكوميه والقصر الرئاسي
يعني هي على بعد اقله عشره كيلو متر عن
القصر الرئاسي والاداره الرئاسيه وحتى
مجلس النواب ومجلس الوزراء لان يعني الحي
الحكومي هو حي ضيق ويقع في بقعه جغرافيه
متداوله قريبه من ساحه الميدان وهي يعني
بالقرب من تقع في وسط عمق وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه ولكن هذه المسيره كانت تسير في
فوق منطقه
الدفاعات الجويه المضادات الارضيه تحاول
اصطيادها قبل ان يعني يطلق صاروخ من
منظومه دفاعيه جويه اصاب تلك المسيره التي
اشتعلت وسقطت على احد المنازل مما سببت
الى حريق صغير تم يعني معالجته بشكل سريع
وبعد حوالي ثمانيه او تسع دقائق كانت
المسيره الثانيه تقوم بطيران دائري فوق
منطقه هالاسكي وسالومسكي رايون تم
استهدافها ايضا بصاروخ من الدفاعات الجويه
وسقطت على احد المحال التجاريه وسببت بعض
يعني الحريق الطفيف كما ذكر عمده
انه لا اصابات بسبب هاتين المسيرتين يعني
عند
الساعه الثامنه والثلاثه وثلاثين دقيقه تم
اطفاء الانذار الجوي في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف وبدات الحياه تعود
تدريجيا الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف بعد
حوالي 30 دقيقه من الانذار الجوي وحوالي 7
او 8 دقائق من اصوات الاطلاق النار
والدفاعات الجويه التي كانت تستهدف هاتين
المسيرتين وبحسب شهود اعيان ان الفارق بين
اسقاط المسيره الاولى والمسيره الثالثه
الثانيه لم يتجاوز السبع الى ثمانيه دقائق
محمد يعني اعطيتنا شرح مفصل حول هذه
المسيرات ولكن هل هذا الامر الذي حصل
اليوم يمكن اعتباره بانه تهديد غير مسبوق
ام عاده المسيرات تحلق بمثل هذه المناطق
ويتم استهدافها هذه المره الاولى التي
تحلق مسيره في منطقه
عاده منطقه
من المدخل
الجنوبي للعاصمه الاوكرانيه كان يسقط عدد
من المسيرات التي كانت متجهه من الجهه
الجنوبيه باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كانت
الدفاعات الجويه تستهدف يعني تلك
المسيرات خاصه مسيرات شهيد ولكن يعني
المسيره التي تم اسقاطها في منطقه هي
المره الاولى التي يتم وبحسب متابعتنا
خلال الفتره الاخيره هي المره الاولى التي
يتم اسقاط مسيره يعني هي يمكن القول
الاقرب الى وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
والحي الحكومي ولكن يعني كما ذكر حذيفه
وكما راينا وتابعنا بحسب تسجيلات الفيديو
وما يتداول عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ان تلك المسيره لم تحلق فوق القصر الرئاسي
او المجلس النواب او مجلس الوزراء او الحي
الحكومي بل كانت على بعد اقله يعني تسع
الى عشره كيلو مترات بالنسبه لوزاره
الدفاع دائما ما هو تعليقها على موضوع
المسيرات حرب المسيرات هل كان لديها
تصاريح حول ذلك هل هناك اجراءات معينه
تتخذ بسبب كثره هذه المسيرات فوق الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يعني بدايه استهداف المحطات
الكهرباء في العاصمه الاوكرانيه في السابع
من شهر اكتوبر من العام الماضي كان من
خلال مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع شاهد تم
اطلاقها وكانت يعني هناك بعض الارتباك من
القوات الاوكرانيه بالتعامل مع تلك
الاسلحه ولكن مع تلك المسيرات ولكن تطور
نظام يعني الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
وحصلت اوكرانيا على مساعدات من الدول
الغربيه واصبحت الان تعرف كيفيه يعني
بدانا نرى دفاعات يعني مضادات خاصه لتلك
المسيرات وانظمه الدفاع حصلت تلك المسيرات
وكما يعني راينا خلال شهرين حتى اليوم
معظم او يمكن قول 90% من المسيرات التي
تطلق على الاراضي الاوكرانيه الجيش
الاوكراني اصبح يقوم باسكاط جميع هذه شكرا
محمد
طبعا مشاهدينا هذه الساعه الاخباريه انتهت
ولكن التغطيه دائما مستمره على شاشه
العربيه والان مع زميل طاهر ملكي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات